[Music]
in north texas this morning a small town
police officer is charged with murder in
the killing of a black man jonathan
price was shot dead
reportedly while trying to break up a
fight saturday night
his family's attorney says he was
unarmed at the time maria viral spoke
with price's family
before the charges against the officer
were announced
wolf city police officer sean lucas was
booked monday night charged with murder
and his bond set at one million dollars
the texas rangers say lucas was
responding to a disturbance call outside
a gas station on saturday
that's when officer lucas encountered
price who the texas rangers say
resisted arrest in a non-threatening
posture
and walked away officer lucas according
to the rangers then
tased price before shooting and killing
him
this video captured the chaos saturday
night
the circumstances surrounding lucas's
decision to use deadly force is now
under investigation
according to family members it was price
who intervened and de-escalated a fight
between a couple
his father junior price says he showed
up to the scene on saturday as
paramedics worked to save him
what do you remember of that moment
watching my son die i knew he was dead
before he moved
hundreds gathered to peacefully honor
price monday night marching the streets
of wolf city about 70 miles outside
dallas price's sister april lewis says
he worked for the city
he was also described as a hometown hero
and a stand-up guy
he had a bright future he was going to
start up his own business fitness center
and it's just it's gone
i mean didn't have to end like that
civil rights attorney lee merritt
represents the price family
they deserve to know every detail about
what happened they need to know it
immediately
still his big sister april is skeptical
they'll get answers
i just want some kind of closure that's
all i want
the family attorney tells us there is
surveillance video of the shooting and
they are working with the texas rangers
to see that very soon
and they are also planning to file a
lawsuit in this case
tony maria thank you very much part of
what stands out in this case in addition
to the fact that the officer was charged
and charged so quickly quickly
is uh price was childhood friends with
will middlebrooks who was a former
infielder for the red sox uh
and middlebrooks has gone online and
taken to defend his friend and say
he wasn't a criminal he wasn't resisting
arrest this is racism
pure and simple and we've got to look at
it as such i like how he says no excuses
this time
he was a criminal nope not this time he
resisted arrest
just to comply and just to comply with
cops nope that doesn't work either
this was purely an act of racism we
should say
and mr middlebrooks is white he said i'm
sick i'm heartbroken and i'm furious
and he's telling other white people who
are coming at him online to take a step
back this time
how many times though guys do we have to
keep telling this story
and nothing seems to change well
hopefully we'll get the surveillance
footage
that they believe is out there and we'll
see it
yeah let's try to do the right thing all
right marie thank you very much